hello and welcome to PlayStation granade
Star Wars Battlefront 2 introduces us to
a story-driven campaign which was sadly
completely missing from its predecessor
we've recently seen the first three
chapters of the story and we've come to
the conclusion the game's protagonist
iDEN versio is a complete badass his
four reasons why we want I plan on
saying badass a few too many times in
fact I'll say it until you agree with me
that it should be in the dictionary
anyway let's do this iDEN versio is the
cream of the galactic crop and is the
commanding officer of infernal squad
which come on it couldn't sound more
badass if it tried she is excellent with
weaponry and isn't afraid to throw a
shifty elbow in the battle she's so
aware of her surroundings
iDEN can shoot out door panels to close
off enemy reinforcements to add to all
this badassery just check out her escape
plan understood commander prepare for
extraction
[Music]
idn't versio is fighting for a losing
side when the game first begins and if
you've seen Return of the Jedi what am i
saying of course you've seen Return of
the Jedi well here on Endor iDEN was one
of the Empire's forces eventually beaten
by the brilliance of the unstoppable
Ewoks ok so she'll probably omit that
from her baddest resume but that's not
my point not only did they lose the
battle but they lost their home to isin
watches as the Death Star is once again
blown to smithereens what I really like
here is that she wanted to burst into
tears of remorse but she sold by us her
priorities are for her team burst
look alive agents we can grieve later
right now we need to move
if Star Wars has taught me anything it's
that you're only as good as your droid
and also your droid needs a gimmick too
c-3po was blinging with gold r2d2 looked
like an adorable dustbin and bb-8 could
roll around with glee
I'd ins partner in crime is a seeker
droid with the adorable name ID 10 he's
a crafty little bugger who becomes a
trendy backpack miss versio can wear of
course it's not all about curb appeal ID
10 has skills to rely on so he can
rescue his master and if you're still
wondering oh yes we will be controlling
this floating backpack in various points
in the campaign ID 10 can electrocute
rebels scan for enemies and do the one
thing robots were created for hacking
doors once the Death Star is no more we
get to see items badass piloting skills
flying through the wreckage whilst
taking part in dogfights demonstrates
Eden's accuracy and her downright skill
defending other pilots from those pesky
rebels
I didn't even flies inside a ship to
prove her but a solution for every
badass has a weakness mine is cheesecake
and what about Aiden well I'm expecting
the story of battlefront to to uncover
the motivations and limitations of Aiden
and what she'll do after the Emperor
went back expect to see her torn over
the actions of her employer which
coincidentally include her father
awkward and also remember no one is the
bad guy in their own story
the Emperor's dead so what happens now
we returned so there you go there's four
reasons why I didn't versio is a
complete badass who else is ready to
represent the Empire and take down the
rebel scum I'd love to know your
thoughts below I'm still a little
skeptical about those loot boxes we
experienced during the open beta but in
terms of gameplay Star Wars Battlefront
2 is a great game or rather a badass
game alright ok I'll stop saying about
us now I apologize my name is Adam from
Playstation grenade it's been a pleasure
I'll see you next time
you
but us